This is a terrible loss.
I just wanted to say how truly sorry I am.
How did you know Gordon?
He saved my life.
He was found dead in his office with gunshots in the wall.
Gunshots?
No bullet wounds.
He was working with a lot of troubled people.
We need to find out what happened to you, Gordon.
It's the least I can do.
I can't see your memories, but I can see the memories of those near you.
Who are you?
I'm working for his widow.
I knew you saw him that night.
I loved him.
Can I help you?
Yes. Alison?
Alison is dead.
You think they're hiding something?
There are people looking for you.
A man has been murdered, I got bigger things to worry about.
Word cannot get out about Gordon's death.
What do you want from me?
I wanted to ask you questions about Gordon Dunn.
Get out!
The mind forgets things for a reason.
There are adverse effects in the machine.
Time collapse, hallucinations.
Do you know who this is?
Lawton has been lying.
I think I know who killed Gordon.
I would hate it if I found out that you were lying.
You have something you wish you could forget?
Who are you?
Put it down.
Put it down!
Help me!